Never give more than five free leads to close a deal never ever ever never ever ever never ever ever. I know for me before I had my process before I was a lab in 20 it was where I was a scientist in a lab.
Coming up with this process and just breaking it down piece by piece.
I thought for some reason I need to set to send leads for three weeks two weeks a month 20 leads 2530 leads.
I just thought that's what you needed to do I thought you need to send a certain number of leads. You do not need to send more than five leads, and a lot of cases I send three, and some cases I send one.
Never send more than five free leads there's a sweet spot when you send a couple. It's, it's sexy it's interesting it's okay I'm playing along.
But when you send too many over too long a period of time that sexiness that newness that value starts to get diminished starts to get watered down, and they, they almost become entitled.
As if you need to keep giving them leads until they close the deal it's like bitch I ain't wait for you to close the deal. That's not the arrangement. If I was closing these deals I go start my own company, you got to close a deal.
I'm letting you test these out right home advisor didn't even let you have one for free.
Angie's list sure didn't let you have one for free, and Google ads didn't give you any lead you just got a bunch of clicks that led to wasted money.
I'm giving you cold heart well warm hard leads these people actually want these estimates.
So guys, never give more than five free leads and less if it feels right and they feel ready. Okay.